britains vote to leave the European
Union makes one thing very clear Europe
needs to rethink one of its core
principles this is a so-called fourth
freedom meaning free movement of people
in addition to the e use guarantee of
free trade in goods services and capital
a degree of control over immigration
policy needs to be given back to
national governments freedom of movement
is enormously valuable making it easy
for any EU citizen to live and work
anywhere in the EU and it fits with the
e u--'s ambition to build an Ave a
closer Union which is why it's being
granted a kind of sacred status Europe's
leaders insist that the Four Freedoms
are indivisible but freedom of movement
clashes with rising fears over
immigration which are helping to fuel
anti-eu populism not just in Britain but
in many other countries as well recently
the EU has been even less popular in
France one of the architects of the
original project and in Britain the
fears are exaggerated countries like the
UK need immigration to fuel economic
growth but the fears are real and
they're dangerous Europe's ongoing
refugee crisis has made matters worse
voters everywhere feel the government's
are ignoring them this helps explain not
just brexit and the rise of parties like
the National Front in France but Donald
Trump's success in the United States too
we have to stop people from pouring into
our country liberal rules for migration
would still be possible even with some
control given back to national
government but the main thing is to
stifle anti-eu populism by bringing the
contentious issue of immigration back
into the realm of national policy and
Democratic choice
if this had been done before the brexit
vote would likely have gone the other
way is too late to do much about that
but flexibility on the fourth freedom
can help the rest of the EU bend before
it breaks